right so here's just a simple example I
just made up these numbers just so I can
get creating more ingredient to you can
see that it really doesn't matter what
your y-intercept is it doesn't factor at
all into the way you're going to get
your solution here okay because you can
move them up or down wherever and the
angle will remain the same
okay so let's start off by saying you
can actually just quote mr. Dahle
tan-theta that angle between the two
lines is going to be equal to now think
in terms of your tan extension as you go
through these numbers okay I want to put
this right here which is green in two
and this gradient which is creating one
I want to put them in that order
okay so I go m1 minus m2 divided by one
plus the product of those okay so that
gives me 1 over 3 10 feet up all right
grab your calculator out this topic
confusingly is generally done in degrees
so make sure you're in the correct mode
okay so I'm not interested in the
accuracy so much I just want to get the
general thing so we can see what's going
on to the nearest degree I'm getting 18
degrees things that checking out you
guys doing this evening
yes I've even got my calculator yeah
okay great
no worries so 18 degrees now does that
look about right looks okay right I mean
I know my own my diagram is not perfect
but it does look like it's in the
ballpark okay now let's just consider
for a second what would have happened if
I did the order the on way round right
if my idea if I swap them around I did
instead 1 minus 2 over 1 plus 2 what
difference would it make
well you can see because in the
denominator you've got M 1 Institute
okay
so multiplication it doesn't matter what
order you put things in so my
denominator will still be 3 ok so no
change there but on the numerator the
only difference is as we switch them
around I've now turned that negative
okay now because 10 is a it's an odd
function right so when you slap in 10
universe both sides he bethany is equal
to minus 18 okay now now you tell me
it's minus 18 what does it mean to think
about it ah okay all right now it's a
bit unclear for now
feedback this way this study that we're
after right I'm not try to solve an
equation I'm trying to measure an angle
when you're measuring things like
measuring a peg or measuring a time that
kind of thing measurements should be
positive right so actually theta equals
minus 18 doesn't really make sense so
how do I get it into the domain what is
the domain for theta
yeah that's right maybe you can see
right the the domain here is actually
from naught to 180
okay I couldn't have a reflex angle to
between the two lines because then
they've been okay so how do I get from
this
what is this related angle 4 1 between 0
1 8 I've got a and 180 don't know so
instead of minus 18 I really should say
162 right does that make sense okay so
what have I worked out I've worked out
the other end with the obtuse angle okay
now you remember I said before when you
get questions like this 95% of the time
they will say work out each Yongle okay
so if we want to work out the acute
angle what order should you put the
gradients in think about it yeah exactly
all I want is for the tan value to be
positive okay so if I've got two one
I'll put two first because it's bigger
that's going to give me a positive value
at the end okay yeah I'm going to I'm
going to discourage the use of absolute
value because it kind of strips away
like what does it mean what does it
actually tell you and also for the 5% of
times when you're looking for the obtuse
angle right absolute value will not help
you right you've actually got to add 180
so he's what I'm gonna recommend he's
I'm gonna recommend they're going to
give you too much and say work out for
instance work out the acute angle okay
so in that case if you know you're after
the acute angle just put the bigger one
first and then subtract the smaller
that's all big - small if what you're
after is an acute angle between the two
lines okay now that's not always what
they're gonna ask you for business
actually rub up the whole thing for it
says sometimes they will say here's two
lines okay they'll give you a third one
like say something like that okay with a
third grade you and then you say what
they'll ask is okay tell me what the
angles are within the triangle that they
form okay so they'll say look whoops
there's one two three angles okay now in
this case or in all cases you know two
of them will be cute they might all be
acute but one might be obtuse as it is
in this case okay so therefore when
you've drawn it out then you'll know
which one you're going to go for and
which one you should say okay I'm gonna
add one into that because clearly it
looks obtuse okay so if they're not just
asking for an acute angle you really
ought to say the safest option is just
draw a rough sketch okay because
otherwise like even if I knew what these
values all were I don't know I mean I'm
not I'm not intuitive enough to know
which ones are going to be acute which
ones are gonna be obtuse
right away I need to have like a rough
sketch there okay and remember they're
not marking your sketch it's just your
tool to work out which ones are gonna be
cute and which ones are obtuse that's